4 and it's friday friday so we're
checking in with our friend mercedes
martinez live from the mix 941 studios
alex did that catch you off guard i'm so
proud of you
john i'm so friendly i'm trying all
right so let's see uh what's trending on
this friday morning hi mercedes
it's good to see you hi guys gotta get
down on friday
first up there's been a break
in the case for strip headliner lady
gaga
lapd arrested five people for stealing
her dogs in february
now the police say four of the suspects
are known gang members
lady gaga's dog walker also got shot
during the incident and he has since
recovered
all the dogs were found and returned to
the singer
next up the billboard music award
nominees were just
announced and even though country singer
morgan walling got
six nods awards show producers say he is
not allowed to win
or perform because of his recent conduct
which included saying a racial slur
he has since apologized meanwhile the
weekend received the most
nominations he is up for 16 awards
including top artists
de baby which i know is your favorite
john he is behind him with 11 nods
and country singer gabby barrett rounds
out the top three
with nine nominations the billboard
music awards will be given out on may
23rd john alex yeah i'm a huge fan of
who is it again dot baby yes
i have the the baby i have it streaming
cds
uh cassettes vinyl all the whole thing
all right let's go well you know
once you're in you're in okay let's
switch gears a little bit here now if
you've ever gotten a mcflurry
maybe you've done this before you've
gotten the spoon you didn't know that it
was actually a big straw or vice versa
and you're not alone alex yeah john gets
distracted when he listens to the baby
he doesn't know
but apparently mercedes a lot of people
thought this was
the wrong thing yeah who
knew it's not working
is so funny because mickey d says the
hollow spoon
is actually a key piece of the mixing
process
it's not something to slurp off the
melted ice cream now it attaches
to the machine and it really helps to
mix in the ingredients
so as a way to make it up to everyone
who is misled mcdonald says they are
going to give folks
a free caramel brownie mcflurry on may
4th
that is on tuesday you'll have to order
it through the app
and pick it up but i guess it's their
way of apologizing for throwing us
off this whole time talking alex they
probably
enjoyed watching people get their
mcflurry but you figured out pretty
quick
i mean clearly it's not a straw yeah or
yeah and i'm not getting any ice cream
that's probably a signal